the media industry is collapsing it's
called the trump slump
so i i saw these stories and in line
with me just like not really caring i
just tweeted the lines to that song
i don't want to set the world on fire i
think it's called that oh yeah
i just want to start a flame in your
heart
and it's an image of huffington post
laying people off
followed by the intercept saying since
trump left office our our
memberships and revenue has dropped
precipitously cnn prime time ratings
collapsing
more than 100 workers laid off from nbc
bloomberg lazy laying people's
laying people off track academic slam
sinclair broadcast layoffs
then we have hallmark channel which is
not super news and then
news sites show early sign of post-trump
slump this is it without donald trump
they will not exist i love how people
are like good song that's great and then
people are commenting
you know fallout whatever because the
song's right but
these are just a small sampling of the
trump slump without donald trump to
attack
and degrade they have nothing the the
best the best i i i gotta read this for
you guys
from the intercept since donald trump
left office on january 20th donations to
the intercept have gone down sharply
after years of steady growth last month
brought fewer newer members than we've
seen in more than two years
similar trends are being reported across
media and progressive politics
while trump railed against journalists
as the enemy of the people grassroots
outrage over trump's corruption racism
and incompetence
fueled a spike in ratings subscriptions
and fundraising that became known in the
industry as the trump bump
well i can say this my respect to the
intercept for admitting
they were just monetizing people's anger
at donald trump
and that now that he is gone they're
desperate and aren't making any money
they drove out glenn greenwald because
glenn greenwald was critical of the
democrats and joe biden
so he ended up having to resign from his
own outlet now who wants to give any
money but i'll tell you what the crazy
thing is
you got matt tybee glenn greenwald matt
tybee formerly of rolling stone glenn
greenwald
founder formerly of the intercept they
started something called a sub stack
were they right now on their own with no
you know boss telling what they can or
can't say
and people pay directly i am a proud
paying subscriber to both glenn and matt
because i think they do amazing jobs
i've been critical of glenn greenwald in
the past i do not think he's perfect but
i respect him for
being for for being consistent for
talking about what he believes for
writing these stories
and it was a tremendous sign of
integrity when he walked from the
intercept his own company
because they were trying to suppress
negative information on the buttons
well the trump slump is here any of you
surprised
not at all i think this is the democrat
party on full display right
you want to keep a problem around
without
actually solving it so you can point at
the problem and say hey
we need more money or more of this in
order to solve this but they never do
and now that president trump is gone
well
the trump slump is here oh man it's
hilarious i said
you know like a month before the
election the best thing for democrats
would be
if trump wins because the establishment
right now has tacit support from the
progressives because they all hate trump
that's the only thing
unifying them and the media will cease
to exist without donald trump
i mean that figuratively the ratings
will collapse and there will be a
bloodbath there will be layoffs
there will be business you know
newsrooms will close down
and it's happening it was like people a
lot of people probably wanted trump out
office so they could go back to sleep
consciously regular people yeah i think
with the media
it's the it's the goose that laid the
golden egg donald trump was laying
golden eggs on twitter every day daily
daily hourly yeah sometimes too much
but the media was able to use all of it
the obsession with trump it's a it's
an amazing thing i'd love to get an
objective like academic review from a
legitimate academic
on like the trump psychological effects
on people
why everyone was so obsessed with
knowing what he was doing or thinking
even even like look he's a celebrity
right the apprentice
people just love the idea of donald
trump what did barack obama say
the american dream is to be trump he
said that like the 90s or whatever
donald trump was the
guy the symbol of american success the
golden toilet he has in
his in his condo up in trump tower there
was an obsession with him
and when he ran for office and he and
and even before he won
the the people who hate him just they
loved to hate him
yeah he was like a hard worker very
physic like
fiscally successful you know came from a
hard family his dad was also a very hard
worker since he was 14
um but he was a jerk and like a mean not
not
i don't know no his dad was apparently
and so was donald he had a lot of those
like dislikable angry he'd get angry
whatever yeah i've not heard that i
haven't heard a lot i don't know him so
it's hard to say but he didn't
say stuff that was very crass and rude
and so it was the dichotomy of a very
successful businessman that
really liked the american dream but also
like a a crude dude
in his campaigns right and in his
private conversations that get released
you hear trump as a rude and crude dude
and a rude crude loot dude
but uh i went to i went to trump tower
um
you know during the campaign and i went
to is an ice cream shop there in new
york and they have the steakhouse
and i just asked people like hey have
you ever seen trump down here the
employees say yeah of course and i was
like what are you thinking like he's
awesome
yeah and they would tell me stories
about how he would come down with a
stack of 100 bills and just hand them
out to everybody
just here's here's a personal gift from
me to you don't worry about it it's tax
gift it's 100 bucks
do whatever you want there's even a
video after he left office recently in
the past couple weeks
where he like walks up to some lady and
he hands her a 50 bill and he like
smiles and she's like oh my
thank you wow the stories i've heard
about donald trump in private are always
that he's a really calm and nice guy
that's about it the people who work
there seemed to enjoy working for him
they said he was great
they loved it when he was around because
it meant he was going to come and hook
him up and take care of him
but then when it came to the when it
came to the presidency he
look trump did say a lot of things that
really aggravated a lot of people
he said a lot of things that i wasn't a
big fan of seemed
i didn't you know maybe maybe trump was
always like that would you know
he tweeted a lot about obama and
birtherism and stuff like that not a fan
of any of that
so i definitely think he's a rude crude
and lewd dude but when people saw him in
person
he seemed to have been genuinely super
charismatic yeah easy to like
also easy to hate it was kind of
depending on what he felt like doing for
the day
you know i think it's more so if you're
mean to him he gets really angry
and then he's vengeful probably very
vengeful vindictive i don't know about
vengeful so
i i heard that he actually paid
somebody's medical bills do you guys
know if that's true
i mean probably i would i wouldn't be
supposed to there's like a big story
super generous guy
yeah well look it's easy to be generous
when you're rich i don't care if it's
trump or oprah but yeah
it's true he's born into it too born
into just a million multi-million dollar
industry
yeah but he did work to continue it i
think i don't know do you know much
about his
his fiscal life did he just kind of
maintain the business or did he grow he
grew
up his own business he got a loan from
his dad he started his own real estate
company and it was bigger and more
successful than his dad's company nice
and uh the the haters it's just i don't
think it's easy to be generous when
you're rich i think you're generous
but it's not right being generous is is
not everyone is
it's it's like oprah gave gives away
cars and stuff and everyone's like wow
it's so nice
no no no it's the companies pay for it
the companies are like oprah will you
give away our cars so that we can get
more people to drive these cars
yeah it's an ad camp there's lots of
rich people that don't do that though
sure
sure sure the thing about trump that i
don't like is you know like dude
don't make me say something that's not
true i can't stand that so when they
were like trump's a failed businessman
his
he bankrupted a casino and i'm like all
of these casinos went bankrupt
it was it wasn't just trump's trump
casino and he had like what 500
businesses and five bankruptcies or
something like that i don't know listen
bankruptcy isn't failure no bankruptcy
means that you don't got to pay back
your debtors and you get to keep your
business your
business it's a protection lots of
people are encouraged to do it if they
have too much credit card debt right
you're better off declaring bankruptcy
and then paying waiting after seven
years getting off your credit report but
it's not even that it's the idea like if
you have a business
and you have more liabilities than
revenue and your business will fail
if you lose access to certain things you
declare bankruptcy you get protected and
your business operates to try and
recover
so it's like dude to claim that donald
trump was stupid
or a bad businessman i'm like just stop
lying
does it make you feel better to say he's
worse he is he is a
a billionaire president who married this
model
like come on man many models and he had
a huge hit tv show like
literally the american dream became
pretty there's a lot of things to insult
the man for there's a lot of things to
criticize him for but i just can't stand
the lies i just i just that's what i
hate about the whole thing
and the lies were so intense it was just
an endless spree of like let me defend
trump again i guess
because they just want you to live in
this fake reality where the orange man
is the villain
yeah there's a lot of things wrong with
trump but they just really really loved
to hate them i wonder if they're going
to villainize biden
with this me too stuff if they're like
using this on cuomo they're going to
wait a little while
see if biden screws it up and then hit
him and put kamal into office
you think so scott they'll only do it
to throw him under the bus when they no
longer need him
and yes they i mean look at what they're
doing at cuomo yeah but everybody loves
a good villain look at the end of the
day
good heartwarming wonderful stories
don't sell
true you know look at the way the
republican party you know treats
aoc she's the pariah and now
look at the way the left is responding
to people like marjorie taylor green
to madison cawthorne to uh lauren
bobert i believe that's how you
pronounce her name out of colorado
those are the new aocs of the right that
they are demonizing and that they are
villainizing
and that's because it sells it's a click
it's a uh media hit and uh it's
unfortunate that those are the people
that they
target and set their sights on who's
cawthorne he's uh the
the young gentleman out of north
carolina who just became a
congressman i think he's the youngest
congressman in history 25 years old
that's like the minimum age isn't it yes
yeah yeah he was actually 24 when he was
running
and he turned 25 subsequently after
being
elected wow and uh and yes he's the
earl youngest congressperson good for
him he did tweet when he won
crime more libs and i was like nah nah
dude none of that
you know but he's a young guy so you
know whatever man uh
we'll we'll we'll see what he ends up
doing and if he if he acts a fool
and you know then i'll criticize him the
same as i would for anybody else
but uh i i did i really do try to to
find stories where i can be
like i like rashida taleb and aoc for
these things because i don't like that
like i only ever see the worst in them
you know what i mean
that's why it's like i try to say can
you name a good democrat can we like can
we find these people and give them
credit when where credit is due
it's difficult i'll give credit what aoc
did in texas
i mean look anybody can say oh she
should be focusing on her district she
should be focusing on new york look
it's an objectively good thing
that she raised and helped raise
millions of dollars for the people of
texas
that is objectively good and
nobody can say otherwise and quite
frankly where were
republicans on the right doing the same
thing now i did see some people who were
out
organizing food and delivering food and
doing things like that but where were
people on the right
getting millions of dollars like the
left did yeah
well it was an opportunity for aoc and
i'll say this there's a lot of people
who are like she's just trying to
exploit situation for political gain and
my response is like oh no
like aoc is helping people in texas
it's like you cleaning up dare her yeah
right oh geez
you know what if she earns political
points because she helped people in a
crisis she deserves them
same for you scott if you if you earn
points because you got a bunch of the
cleanup
trash you deserve them so it's like by
all means from your place
and it just makes us look petty right if
we attack someone for doing something
good you know let's
real quick let's let's make the
political battle about who can do the
most good
yes let's be like oh aoc how she she's
she's winning the fight and helping
people who are in poverty ted you got to
go in there and raise more money and
help more people
sure just for the record did you clean
up the trash to score
to get political clout the people what
was yours i did it because nobody
else was doing it and i thought wow i
have a responsibility with this platform
see people don't understand
i actually feel a heavy weight on my
shoulders and because i've been gifted
with this large social media platform
that's the reason why i work non-stop
and why i actually feel guilty taking
days off because i feel like number one
who else is gonna do it and and i
challenge you at home please do it i
want you to do what i do i don't
i don't want all of this on my shoulders
and that's why i consistently work and
i'm
going towards 2022 because i feel like i
have this
moral responsibility to use my platform
for good
hold on i want it to be about political
points i absolutely do
i want everyone out there to know that
you will make your political faction
look good when you go clean up your city
clean up trash raise money to help poor
people raise money to feed feed those
that are hungry and provide shelter to
the homeless
i want each and every person aoc i
believe deserves tremendous respect for
all of everything that she did in
helping these people and raising this
money i agree and now i challenge
republicans to high-five her and say
we're gonna win the competition next
time because we're gonna help even more
people than you helped
and i want that to be politics imagine
ted cruz comes out
and he's like in my campaign i raised
five million dollars for
for this you know people aoc only raised
three million it's good that she did it
but we
won in helping more people vote for me
and we'll help people i'm like that's
great
like let's do that instead of yelling at
people and wanting to fight each other
um i don't think we've gotten into like
what you've been up to the last
three or four months i think you said
you've changed trajectory a little bit
i have so very much like after the 2016
elections
uh you know hillary clinton had some
ideas of why she lost the election
but the democrats really smart right
what they did
is they changed the law legally
and they started ballot harvesting in
california
and because of that all of orange county
went blue right it wasn't
witchcraft it wasn't shenanigans
they changed the law legally and so
i'm arguing for election integrity
moving forward
that why don't we do the same we control
the state legislature in 23
states we have trifecta governments we
got the governorship we got the state
house we got the state senate
it's within our power to change the laws
legally
to provide for additional election
integrity to fortify the election
right and we control the state
legislatures
in pennsylvania michigan
wisconsin would you look at that swing
states
why don't we do the same and at least
force the governors who are democratic
to veto that legislation which would
have political
leverage repercussions going to the 2022
elections and should we
elect republicans in those states then
let's fortify the elections going into
2024
into the presidential so basically i'm
just saying look
you guys at home you have the power but
it's up to you
if you choose to harness that power and
if you are not
talking to your legislators writing them
emailing them
calling them then quite frankly you
don't really care do you organize
daily phone calls like at 2pm call this
number
well i did just uh read donald trump
jr's
tweet where he was alerting us
about sf 145 which is legislation in
wyoming
that's currently introduced at the
senate committee level
which would allow for primaries
that don't have a clear 50 plus one
winner
it would go to a runoff election
therefore
taking away power from the liz cheney's
so liz cheney wouldn't be able to squeak
out a victory with 13
of the vote or 25 of the vote it would
go to a runoff
election and so yes would she just win
the runoff though not necessarily
not necessarily and so i did send out an
emergency email
to my contacts in wyoming and look at
what's happening in georgia for example
state senate pass legislation that would
allow for voter id for
absentee voting so if people care you
need to call
and get involved especially with
subcommittees where bills go to die
and so two important websites that i'm
asking people to go to are legiscan.com
to find legislation that's being
introduced at the state level and also
balapedia.org
to find more information about districts
that you live in thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you